in a camp in central myanmar a former
policeman gives his full concentration
to his task he's making a gun
something he learned by watching videos
online
the plus point about making our own
weapons
is we don't have to spend a lot of money
buying guns but it takes a lot of time
we have to be extremely careful it can
be dangerous for us if we are careless
he's part of an armed resistance group
known as the people's defense force or
pdf
it's made up of people from all walks of
life united in one goal
fighting the junta
they've given up jobs and left their
homes and families behind to live in
camps like this
here they train plan and carry out
counter-attacks on security forces
they say they're aware of the risks
and know they are outgunned by a
military force that's used artillery
fire and air strikes on civilians
but the fighters know they can count on
the support of many people in myanmar
i feel like they're our strength during
our struggle they protect us from army
dogs the junta forces torch villagers
even though there aren't any armed
fighters there
resistance groups have also stepped in
to provide services disrupted by the
fighting
a nurse who quit her job in a military
hospital to join the civil disobedience
movement last year conducts basic health
checks on people from villages
more than a year after the coup in
february 2021
resistance against the military
government is still strong
small protests like this one in a
village in neighboring sagan region take
place from time to time
they may not be enough to overturn the
military government but the message they
send is loud and clear
florence louis al jazeera